our topic tonight is the amber heard and
johnny depp case so
have any of you heard
amber heard testify
yeah
very wild
if i was a loyal i would be
white to just dismiss myself on the case
um so basically for the people at home
that don't know i'm sure everyone
already has seen this case but basically
a couple years ago
johnny depp and amber heard were in love
they're day in they're having a great
old time they get married right
um until
after it ends amber heard comes out and
says that she was abused
and this was during kind of the me too
era of hollywood like every everyone was
coming out and saying they were like
abused or whatever like left and right
and for the most part companies were
just taking the woman's side
so in this case johnny depp um
was dropped from pirates of the
caribbean
and basically from any major like place
that wanted to do movies with him he was
like dropped all the sponsor is gone
well she didn't name him by name um
she she did a very public article
saying that johnny abused her
so
now
um it's a couple years later
johnny has decided to sue her for 50
million dollars
saying that he was the one being abused
basically
so
yeah defamation
so
um the question that i have
is should women go to prison
for
robbing a man from his livelihood
yeah i think so
since you guys are the ones in the hot
seat i have no words right now
play the fifth
um i can start if you want yeah go ahead
um
not to change your question or anything
i think anybody that wrongly accuses
anyone of anything that impacts their
livelihood should definitely go to
prison
and i think in this case
i've been on the i've been uh on a jury
before you know not in america but here
in london so i can think like a juror
watching johnny depp give his uh
testimony and then watching amber heard
he's more believable yep she's very much
coming across like a fantasist like a
really bad actress personally um i feel
like even her lawyer
man objected his own question
that's funny you know and i just feel
like a lot of the stuff she's accusing
him of like i saw a video where she
accused him of at one time they were in
the car together and apparently had the
dog out of the window and everyone in
the car was shot but then we've seen a
video of her doing the exact same thing
you know with the dog in the car outside
the window so it just seems to me that
everything she's accusing him of
is pretty much the stuff that she's been
doing to him we heard the voice note
oh you're a man you go and tell people
that you're you know you're getting
abused and see if they'll believe you
and that's what happens a lot of the
time so
personally i just feel like
i don't really believe what she's saying
um and i kind of side with johnny depp
on this one
so follow-up question oh okay do you so
let's say
let's say he she was abusing him right
yeah and he hit her back
and she wrote the article detailing
things that she he did do but she just
missed the part where it was in
self-defense oh it just missed
very convenient very convenient yeah
right right do you think in that case
is it still a false accusation
it's not a false accusation but it's
like a half truth you know what i mean
but then again
if he hit her in retaliation then he's
still in the wrong
that one i have to you know
break that down
[Laughter]
i've been in a situation where
i've been slapped i've been punched by a
woman you know she might have gone
through my phone found something wild
you know you know it'd be sometimes
pearl in these streets
you know oh you know do tell i mean it
happened it happened you know you're not
adolescent yeah you know what i mean you
know it happened i've been cheated on i
did not slap him he didn't slap him no
was he taller than you smaller than you
bigger than you he was bigger but like
that's why
yeah was she bigger than you i mean she
she we could have gone round around
[Laughter]
like i mean i'm pretty tall i mean you
are you are i just feel like you're
either a girl that hits guys or you're
not dumb
yeah yeah that's true by the way
you're all right without having to go to
five yeah yeah like i mean where do you
stand in the violence
so what if
i used to be i used to think like you
did right so i'd be like no he shouldn't
mention or hit women but it forget let's
say i'll just punch you right now right
let's just say personal
you have i just think like you have
every right seriously yeah like if i
laid hands on you and i know that you
are stronger than me
i know the consequences and a lot of
girls
well let me say a lot of people not look
let me not just say girls but like some
people will take advantage of it like
let's say a woman knows that
he won't hit her back and she'll
continuously do it so i think amber
is like the type of person to do
something like that i agree so like
explaining that like she didn't explain
that he was doing it in self-defense
anyway
so that shows just her character and
what she's willing to do or what she did
do so let me can i say something
i mean in the society we
we live in right
we it's clear that
there's a double standard
right
i believe that for
whether
but in this case we're talking about a
woman right
i strongly believe and advocates for
a woman going to prison going to jail
if you forcefully accuse a man because
in the society we live in this man has
been ripped off his livelihood
everything everything
and the thing is
when a man is accused of like domestic
violence or like rape for example
it's a stigma that never leaks yeah even
if he's found not guilty it never leaves
correct and
acting is this man i've been you know
i've been
watching johnny depp movies since i was
young yeah yeah i was young this is this
man's livelihood
and
even if he's found not guilty there's a
stigma that still remains and from time
women have got gotten away with things
like this it's fact
women know
that
i can do something to you and play the
victim i need to go it's to go my way
women know that's true you know women
know so a woman knows that if
if i hit you
and you hit me back i can play the
victim and you go you you know you get
into trouble
right so
i personally i don't advocate for men
putting their hands on women
but
if i had hands put on me i'm putting my
hands back on you unfortunately
if
you know if man if you put your hands
down and put my hands back on you man it
is what it is like the [ __ ] is equal
rights equal legs
you can pick and choose when it comes to
equality you have to take everything the
good and bad you can pick and choose i
wouldn't put my hand on the woman you
can call me every name in the book
that's fine
but when you cross that line
if i decide not to hit you back
it's me doing your doing you a favor
you don't tell me what if you hit me i
decide okay not to retaliate it's me
deciding that not
it's not cause
you know
i just think like if a skinny dude walks
up to a bigger dude right and hits him
he's like he's good will and chris yeah
that was a good example yeah but i don't
like more like more like okay if chris
hit will okay first yeah
then like will hit him back and he got
knocked out yeah like nobody would
question nobody cares yeah yeah
but if a weaker woman hits a man
and gets knocked out but i think it's
like that sympathy sort of
you know people automatically get
because
everybody roots for the underdog
and i think in that scenario all the
time nine out of ten women will always
be the underdog
and i feel like that's why
you have the imbalance
where
even if she hits you
the world expects you as a man
because of how strong you are the
strength you have
to be able to restrain yourself
and that's where i think you have the
disparity and
that's even kind of like playground
that's exactly where i stand i've been
hit before i've never been hit by i have
i've been i've had something thrown at
me like close range what was it it was a
bag you died yeah what you ducked it no
no he slapped me in the face
it's all right you know what i'm saying
if that was a bomb yeah if it was a
bottle was different i would have got
knocked out this way
by the time i woke up
but i don't i don't think i think
because of the disparity as you said
between like male and female strength i
don't think we should be hitting women
like regardless of if she has slapped
you wherever she does to you your own is
to try and um
restraint de-escalated escalate the
situation restrain her what if she
brings a knife oh yeah then defend
herself like try and take the knife off
her obviously you're not gonna know i
don't know about to try and stop it
did he try to defend himself or did he
get a knife
but that's a completely different
situation he's not here to explain
himself we we we can't we can't liken
the two one one is fists and one is
knife that's two different things what
would you do
that's never gonna happen
if your
person came to you with a knife i'm
cutting bro i'm running i'll be honest
with you
what you i'm gonna i'm gonna stand there
and fight someone has a knife i mean
male or female bro
i mean okay like i think like you're in
a room right you guys are room you can't
get out yes she has a knife on you i
have to punch her up bro
simple with it